[Music]
sir 18 months the election is over now
we can get back to what's really
important what the hell is going on with
Bruce Jenner's face that's what we need
to be talking about in this nation I
think he's just just constantly being
terrified by somebody that was a crazy
night did you stay up late watching the
result I did yeah I stayed up it was
great
and if you saw who saw the president's
victory speech last night he was here
and then you switched immediately over
to this program right here a couple of
you did in his victory speech last night
President Obama told his daughters that
they would not be getting another dog
yeah when asked why the president said
because I just made Mitt Romney my
I'm repeating what I heard him say that
really got Bill O'Reilly worked up yeah
he had a stroke after that you know what
made a big difference last night his
Hispanic vote we had a big difference in
this number yeah yeah I'm with you
amigos I don't think I convinced anybody
with that Knossos true the president got
70% of the Hispanic vote in Colorado and
Nevada 70% yeah
and in New Hampshire Obama got the
support of both Latino guys Carlos and
his cousin Carlos both solidly yes yeah
they're tapping from people sugar Mitt
Romney did well with certain voters too
though because it was close he did well
Mitt Romney had the support of men
people over 45 and married women yeah
you know the words Mitt Romney had the
support of MIT and Ann Romney solidly in
their corner right a lot of Republicans
are upset and they're kind of trying to
mow it over today yeah I figure out
what's going on yeah today one
Republican leader said his party is
quote too old to white and to male you
can read the rest of his comments on his
MySpace page
yesterday wasn't historic day everyone
marked it in different ways yesterday a
Kenyan woman true story a Kenyan woman
gave birth to twin boys and named them
Barack Obama and Mitt Romney yeah
obviously she named the one that came
out second Mitt Romney I'm telling you
what happened
I don't comment on these I just eat
artichokes yeah well you don't know what
those are a lot of celebrities tweeting
last night yep celebrities tweeting
about the election during election
coverage last night Hugh Hefner tweeted
it's just too close to predict how it's
gonna turn out it's scary yeah of course
that's what Hefner always tweets on his
way to the bathroom
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
four more years of that yesterday Maine
and Marilyn approved gay marriage
and today Delaware confessed to being
bicurious notice Delaware kind of
looking over there kind of obvious have
lunch with Delaware you'll find out all
right what else is going on this is
weird very weird story a woman has
published a novel that she wrote
entirely on her blackberry wrote her a
whole novel on her blackberry yeah
the novel's called I wish you were an
iPhone honey boo boo in the news honey
boo boo
yeah why why why honey boo boo has a new
pet chicken named nugget yeah hopefully
things go better for nugget than they
did for her pet pig delicious you don't
name a chicken nugget do you but they do
yeah it's it's perfectly logical to them
because that's where nuggets come from
chickens thanks for explaining it to me
Andy you need any help with with
southern white folks you just come to me
on
I should take a class yeah